How can well-meaning, data-driven,
attempts to solve social problems
actually make things worse?
Campbell's Law may hold the answer.
Crafted by a social scientist nearly
a half-century ago,
the law basically says: "when a measure
becomes a target, it ceases to be a good measure."
The problems play out in many
fields, including education.
Attempts to evaluate schools and teachers based on
reading and math scores cause educators
to do everything possible to boost
results – whether that's narrowing curricula,
going goofy for test
preparation, or cooking the books.
It brings to mind those old Soviet
factories, with their production quotas
and shoddy products. But Campbell's Law
applies to more than test scores.
We've seen it play out when schools are told to
improve school safety numbers or
to drive up graduation rates. Now, none of
this means that we should shy away from
accountability or measurement in
education. But it does mean that we need
to be a lot more attentive to how those
metrics get used. They need to respect the law.
Campbell's law, that is.
How do
you think we should tackle
accountability in American education?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.